turning to Ukraine now Russian forces
attacked several cities with drones
overnight Russia says these strikes are
retaliation for an alleged drone attack
on the Kremlin yesterday now Moscow
claims the target was President Vladimir
Putin and this morning a top Russian
official accused the U.S of planning it
Charlie Daggett is in dinipro Ukraine
with more on this part of the story
Charlie good morning to you
good morning to you Gail that accusation
came from Kremlin spokesman Dimitri
peskov saying attempts to disown this
from kieving Washington are absolutely
ridiculous those are his words we know
very well decisions on such attacks that
are made not in key but Washington Kiev
is just doing what it's told
Russia had vowed retaliation for this
alleged double drone strike something
the Kremlin called a terrorist act and
an attempt on the life of President
Putin without offering any evidence to
back up the claims but overnight
[Applause]
the Russian military Unleashed a wave of
drones toward Ukraine with Ukrainian air
defense officials saying they destroyed
18 of 24 drones including every single
one headed toward Kiev the third time
the capital has been targeted in four
days
Ukraine said it had nothing to do with
the alleged Kremlin attack accusing
Russia of staging the whole thing the
Ukrainian president putting the blame
firmly at the feet
it's all really simple he said Russia
has no victories he can't send his
soldiers into death anymore he can't
motivate his country anymore now he
needs to find any possibility to
motivate them
even before the Russian announcement the
southern city of kurson bore the brunt
of the payback officials say Russian
shelling killed 21 civilians and wounded
dozens more hitting a supermarket train
crossing and residential homes in an
ominous sign of more trouble ahead a
curfew has been declared for curse on
City through the weekend
some voices in Moscow are now calling
for the direct targeting of President
zielinski himself one General saying
Kiev has crossed another red line
predicting a strike on Ukraine's
presidential Palace in retaliation
Tony
dagada for us in Ukraine Charlie thank
you very much